[Music]
hello we are a cool item why am i
yelling I'm not gonna yell this time I
didn't want to yell that's why I went
really calm away but you're a Yeller you
have a big mouth
be out of left Co are you gonna be
somebody else now let's go
we took our act on the road to take on
the 49ers
the 900 miles amendment one amendment -
hmm Aaron Rodgers Kyle Shanahan we'll
figure out our amendments Vikings could
have lost that game to the 49ers Green -
uh game Bay god bless you and God bless
Aaron Rodgers yes that guy really shrine
together some winning seasons awesome
Wow hey I mean I'm - I can't remember
what exactly I was gonna say we built
your friendship well I mean Parcells
didn't want got him peace bro
matchmaker met to make it make me a
match you're absurd anyways the pizza
I'm Don Corleone I need to shave I'm
five minutes old that's why they call
you mo that's how you say it yeah Italy
[Music]
no way negative Ghost Rider negative
Ghost Rider negative Ghost Rider
negative Ghost Rider the pattern is full
negative Ghost Rider the pattern is full
come let's say ahh --mess Alice - Alice
- sins and lefke the players show and
they can you feel better man well you
were wrong you said Friday that's me
Punch Big Ben in the lag deck oven how
would he procure such saltwater taffy I
don't know what the cure means so you'll
have to explain that to me how did how
did he obtain this saltwater taffy for
cents
peace out homey I am the LEF Keowee man
he's the KOA he'll we're not a small his
name on the next episode of Sims a left
go the show till then we'll have them in
the back learning how to spell what just
happened